I GOT BACK FROM A FAMILY R.V.
TRIP.
THIS MORNING I WATCHED THE
SUNDAY SHOWS TO MAKE SURE I WAS
CAUGHT UP ON THE IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTS.
>> GOOD MORNING, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
THIS WEEK WE SAW HOW MICHEAL
COHEN'S KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S PAST COULD DETERMINE
TRUMP'S FUTURE.
>> LET ME START WITH THE MICHEAL
COHEN SITUATION.
>> THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I WANT TO START WITH MICHEAL
COHEN.
>> I DON'T WANT TO START WITH A
MICHEAL COHEN SITUATION.
I DON'T WANT TO WAIST YOUR TIME
WITH HIM AT ALL.
LIFE.
THIS IS LEADING TO HIGHER
PRODUCTIVITY AND HIGHER INCOME.
WE MUST MAKE SURE WE KEEP THINGS
MOVING AND NOT GO BACK TO THE
BAD OLD DECADES OF WAGE
STAGNATION AND SKYROCKETING
RICHES FOR THE ELITE.
WE NEED TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHY
THE TURN AROUND IS HAPPENING.
WE HAVE A PRO ENTERPRISE
PRESIDENT IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN CONGRESS.
IT'S NOT JUST THE TAX CUTS
INCLUDING THE CORPORATE TAX
CUTS.
SURGE OF BUSINESS CONFIDENCE.
HE'S DELIVERING HIS SIDE OF THE
BARGAIN.
FASTER AND BIGGER.
PERHAPS HIS SUPPORTERS EXPECTED.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING TO
DISTRACT AND DEFLECT.
THIS IS WHY WE SAW THE FAVORITE
TACTIC DISEMPLOYED THIS MORNING.
THEY ARE DISATTACHED
THEY ARE DETATTACHED
THEY ARE DETACTACHED
THEY ARE DETACHECHED
THEY ARE DETACHED FROM WORKING
AMERICA.
HIGH END TV DRAMAS SET IN
WASHINGTON DC LIKE HOUSE OF
CARDS AND SCANDAL HAS GONE TO
THEIR HEADS.
THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE
PARTICIPANTS IN A HIGH DRAMA
GAME.
REAL PEOPLE IN THE REAL WORLD,
MILLIONS OF THEM, ARE SEEING
LIFE GET BETTER FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN A LONG TIME.
THE IYI, INCIDENT ELECTRICAL
IDIOT.